[Music]
for eighty-four thousand dollars an
artist returned two blank canvases
titled take the money and run all right
this particular artist
all right uh received this money from
the museum the money was supposed to be
used to create modern art so they get
commissioned
to create art for their exhibitions and
whatnot uh and it was but not in the way
that the danish museum expected when it
gave that artist the equivalent of
eighty four thousand dollars in kroners
that's art though
they received two uh empty canvases
right i mean he got they got trolled
i'll give you an exact oh that's a nice
canvas two of them very white you got
two of them
all right got it from blick
but buddy titled it uh take the money
and run
right the artist jen's uh haining says
the blank canvases make up a new work of
art title take the money and run that he
calls it commentary on poor wages
one thing it's not he says is a theft
explicitly he still was willing to
comment and still like comment on all
this you know he says uh the danish
museum says it's a breach of contract
and the breach of contract is oh no he
says it's a breach of contract but the
breach of contract is part of the work
that's what makes it what is art how
much the paint weighs on the canvas sirs
he says the work is that i have taken
their money
because in uh in this day and age an
artist uh kind of like
i guess his his idea obviously in modern
art was to be like um basically put you
can a a museum will be willing to like
be like here's a bunch of cash and they
had expected to contract and to take
that money and literally put in the art
to express modern art using the cash
and he called it take the money and run
he because that's modern art he's like
you're willing to pay 84 000 to put in
the art but you won't be willing to pay
the artist to create that i think that's
dope you know what i'm saying in terms
of having that so he's like no i'm
taking that money yeah the only irony in
that is that the contract of the art
piece says that the money that would
have been used to create the art is to
be returned at the end of the contract
in january wait why the [ __ ] would he
return the money if he's doing the work
for i don't get it in terms of using the
actual money to create physical
materials all of it has to be used 84
g's of paint oh no no like money like
literal money cash the paper they have
to tape it to the canvas or something he
was supposed to use that money all right
reversible way where they can take it
back off and yeah yeah that was like the
idea of it oh
yeah that's different then i didn't know
that [ __ ] oh they wanted cash to be used
i believe so yeah are you sure it's not
the cost of the material it's the value
but but the actual they they gave it in
chronos physical bills they wanted to
create an art with it yeah so how would
he do it without damaging the money
and then being able to extract it back
out and glue stick baby yeah
that doesn't damage it so he sends two
large crates to the museum as they uh
prepared to mount the work themed uh
show that opened the previous weekend
and when they opened the boxes they were
surprised to find two blank canvases ceo
of the museum says he actually laughed
as he saw it
and then uh it was obviously titled take
the money and run so he kind of like got
it in the moment um the delivery quickly
provoked a flurry of emails and messages
at the museum anderson says that while
uh the ceo of the the museum he says
that while hannah's initial work
converted money into art the new work
reminds us that we work for money and
also adds a new twist to the debate over
how an artist's work should be valued
hilarious he told the right people but
contractually he still needs to get the
money back oh yeah i mean
but he did his job i mean look we're
talking about it i saw it on instagram
like everyone was talking about it i
mean that's pretty genius he executed
yeah so the museum's not taking legal
action yet but i mean at the end of the
day he like he said he did the job and
it's provocative that's the whole
problem right
and then we're talking about it and
we're just like yeah what is he couldn't
have bought that reach and i didn't know
that that's how they commission artists
either
like how museums i didn't know that they
paid for it i thought it was just um
you have an exhibit because you're being
showcased or a theme or whatever and
then you're just submitting your [ __ ]
that's crazy i don't know if they would
necessarily always pay for it but in
this particular type of art concept if
they're providing like the uh
i guess in this
sense it's the medium yeah right then
that's like slightly different but still
um obviously like like we talked about
like why the [ __ ] would we even know
about any artwork that happens to come
out into a modern contemporary art
museum in you know nobody's talking
about any of that [ __ ] they're talking
about this kind of [ __ ] right yeah so
it's good as much as it's simple i i
guess i always respect any art that's
done cleverly like this the first time
right the second person did it's like
danish dude did it already dude the
banksy shredder move was like the
greatest i [ __ ] love that move so
good
you buy it and it goes
that was the greatest [ __ ] thing and
watching all them was going oh my
[ __ ] god
perfect
and then valuing it even more again well
yeah and then and then going like surely
we can make more money from this huh
i was at the um season caesar forum
shops in vegas and they have stores that
that basically sell like og picassos and
whatever you can buy it
um and then and i was just shocked
because i thought it was just the art
gallery
and it was like cool stuff and then i
walked up and i was like oh
that looks like a picasso
and then the the sales guy was quaint
basically the the guy was like yeah you
know they always say picasso is like the
best uh
i guess copier of his own art and i was
like wait that's original picasso he
goes yeah and i'm like oh [ __ ] these are
all originals because i never seen like
a real one outside of a museum is there
like a price tag on it yeah there you
could you could get some for a couple
grand well some of them are just
sketches and whatever they're not like
the actual pieces that
no they're they're his real copies his
sketches his his his drawings his
some paintings he's like i see his nft
head right now yeah that's what i was
thinking dude i was like
holy crap so okay this is for 600 bucks
this is that and i would go around and
there's like you know rembrandts and all
these other artists that we like learn
about in art history
these are the originals that you can buy
that you can actually [ __ ] and some
of them are just sketches they're not
like full paintings or whatever but
they're still like in the thousands of
dollars
like some like low thousands yeah like
affordable yeah like some of them i saw
one it was like this little etching it
was like 600 bucks
what yeah it's like this small scam guys
almost almost right
now it sounds like it's i need someone
that knows this stuff that could come in
stores
yeah but they you know it's like going
to buy a car right like you you got to
have somebody with you that knows this
stuff and they'll be like yeah that one
that shouldn't be 600 or whatever that
should be five
and i'm like i want to get into art just
for that
just like nft [ __ ] but i was like i
always thought like where do you buy
this stuff like you gotta you gotta go
to an art thief in france and he has a
closet full of [ __ ] monets and [ __ ]
right that's true yeah who do you go to
yeah just a [ __ ] guy with a giant
trench coat
just framed
a little bit
who made that piece back there
oh that's a bart it's a picasso how much
do you think that's worth
this is a bobby lee original
he actually did it during the sketch
i collaborated with sriracha sauce oh
that's sriracha yeah there's sriracha
and this is bobby lee and i'm sure he
touched his nuts at some point and
rubbed it on the painting good nice yup
that was like brush would you appraise
this ad thirty dollars
thirty dollars you should get all the
guests to have some sort of [ __ ]
painting
that's true huh and it was a small one
yeah and we could make a whole wall out
of it as a ryan may original and it's
you know yeah let's do it that would be
cool i have a canvas and some paint too
you just got to put paint on your hair
and you just do like wash it around yeah
that'll be cool then we fill up these
walls with just uh art from guests and
fans we'll devalue these walls yeah
let's do it
the blank drywall's worth more it was
worth way more actually we didn't know
the whole time this drywall looks
expensive as [ __ ] look at it it's been
through a lot i still don't understand
that the penis over there how it's so
good yeah who shake that is that bart
it wasn't meant to be a dick it wasn't
meant to be in a ditch no but barb
elbowed it your elbows the shape of a
penis there's two balls on it there's a
sack on it and a shaft it's not fair to
them they can't see it it's not fair to
them well turn the camera
we could cut that out and then we'll
sell it as an nfp
oh that's a good nft dude i could pick
throw it out
all right
yeah that [ __ ] was pretty dope though
man when he hit it it's definitely [ __ ]
and balls for sure okay especially for
my ankle right here did you know like at
the wind and the encore if you go uh
above a certain floor which you have to
get like a nice enough room to get it
they have like those original da vinci
whatever monets like it's all displayed
in the hallway and stuff there's like
millions and millions worth of painting
how do i protect that [ __ ] he's one of
the most um
biggest collector a private collector of
uh fine art well it's because uh those
rooms are so expensive i think that kind
of like weeds out who would be stealing
or not got it cause it's like just other
crazy ballers that are like oh cool
let's just make it nice how expensive is
the room and it is a casino those things
are pretty it's like a bank you know oh
yeah it's like a resort bank it's 100
bank
the drawing
[Music]
yo let's go get let's go get some art
let's go get some art like real art yeah
real art with our with our [ __ ]
crypto i can't be spending more than 50
bucks
go to art walk that's the limit you guys
50 bucks yo when i come up i'm gonna buy
you guys all some picassos or something
put the sketches but not not the yeah
yeah yeah
i love that when i come up and buy y'all
picasa sketches when i come up that's
some [ __ ] slack still sick though
that's sick has anybody ever told you
that in life when i come up i'm gonna do
this and then they actually came up and
you never got the thing never happened
nah cause i'm usually the richest one in
the room
[Music]
you